une ville devenue le symbole du chaos
semé par la pandémie
ces 2,7 millions d'habitants sont
touchés de plein fouet par la crise
la maire de la ville elles mêmes
contaminées pu guéri semble dépassé par
la situation à guayaquil vu la gravité
de la situation il n'ya de place ni pour
les vivants ni pour les morts nous
sommes à mes yeux au sommet de la courbe
et nous n'avons pas commencé à descendre
je ne vois pas de sortie rapide à ça
pour venir en aide à la population
la ville a lancé un programme dead en
porte à porte des colliers alimentaires
ont ainsi été distribués à 4000 familles
une manière de les soutenir alors que
beaucoup ne peuvent plus subvenir à
leurs besoins
faute de travail nous sommes ici depuis
un mois et aucune aide n'est arrivée
alors maintenant nous sommes
reconnaissants pour cette aide que nous
avons reçues je suis père de quatre
enfants
nous vivons au jour le jour être sans
emploi pousse au désespoir
dans cette ville la deuxième du pays
l'état d'urgence et le couvre-feu de 15
heures par jour n'ont pas empêché la
propagation de l'épidémie
les hôpitaux sont saturés tout comme les
services funéraires
certains cadavres sont retrouvés à même
la rue environ 800 personnes ont été
récupérées chez les habitants dans les
maisons preuve de l'ampleur du désastre
ces images d'un cimetière où l'on creuse
de nouvelles tombes
les autorités prévoient jusqu'à 3500
décès dans les prochaines semaines